We have talked about how important color is
to human beings, that we have thousands of
words to describe many, many different shades
of color.
Color is clearly important to us; it helps
us in our everyday life to be able to describe
objects by their color.
So where does this concept of color come from?
There a number of parts of the process that
lead to you having a perception of color in
your mind and what we are going to do is go
through those from the beginning to the end.
At the start of the whole process we have
what we call an illuminant.
An illuminant is a thing that omits light
and the light shines on the scene, shines
on the object that we are interested in and
we call this incoming light, we call that
the illuminance.
So the illuminance is the light from the illuminant
that falls on the object that we are interested
in.
Now the object reflects some of that light
and the light that comes from the object we
refer to as the luminance, we talk about the
luminance of the object.
In this case we would refer to the luminance
of the apple, so light is coming in from our
illuminant, striking the apple, reflecting
off it and entering the eye of our observer.
Some pretty amazing things happen within the
eye.
The incoming photons trigger a chemical reaction
in the rod and cone cells at the back of your
eye.
They lead, in turn, to electrical impulses
which are transmitted through the optic nerve
to the visual cortex of your brain, which
is located in the back of your head, and that
leads to the perception of the color red.
Which you would associate with the object
you are looking at—in this case, the apple.